[Applaudissements]
les séries sont sera la musique de ce
soir chaque soir je lancerai 1 ce soir
c'est crazy frog déjà su que j'étais
vous allez remarquer changer les
couleurs
ah ouais j'avais besoin de bleu bleu
bleu bleu bleu bleu bleu comme le soleil
maiden comme la radio locale messieurs
exactement mais je vous dise bien de
folie et je vous livre les missions
franchement voilà j'ai je comprends pas
tellement jeune afrique mais en ce
moment moi je trouve que ma singer ça
fait du bien moi je suis toujours
émerveillé par ce qui est enfantin parce
qu'ils nous ramènent à l'enfance fait
kiffer quant au top mais oui parce que
mes parents ils avaient une droguerie
que ça peut être regretter ce serait un
grand bazar comme ça à lyon et vendait
des panoplies et c'était mon jeu préféré
et mon père il mime il mettait des mâles
comme ça entière de d'examiner va avec
tes amis va jouer et c'était mon premier
jeu en fait n'est pas un virus qui a été
manipulée aujourd'hui on est capable
quand on prend la structure génétique
d'un virus de voir s'il a été touché sur
si on a fait ce qu'on appelle des
chimères c'est-à-dire de disjoindre
d'autres d'autres particules d'autres
virus il parce qu'en ce moment c'est
vrai qu'au départ on accusait cet animal
que je connaissais maintenant moi le
pangolin voilà on en a entendu parler
partout et puis de plus en plus même les
gens les plus sérieux vous disent c'est
pas voulu mais peut-être qu'il ya eu une
erreur en laboratoire un accident qui
fait que ce virus est sorti est-ce que
c'est déjà arrivé des erreurs en
laboratoire menant un virus ça pourrait
arriver car ça pourrait arriver alors on
a on a parlé d'un certain nombre
d'épidémie d'épidémie grippale si vous
voulez et fièvre de marburg aussi il y
aurait eu peut-être peut-être un erreur
en laboratoire la fumée là dessus si
vous voulez le gros point
d'interrogation c'est qu'on n'a pas
identifiés l'hôte intermédiaire alors je
vais m'expliquer on s'était pas ce prix
ouais aussi qu'au départ les chauves
souris
c'est d'ailleurs très intéressant elles
ont dans leur organise des dizaines et
des dizaines de virus dont des
coronavirus et d'ailleurs on se demande
en zig mais quel est le système
immunitaire de la chauve-souris qui leur
permet d'être protégé data c'est le
premier point et on sait qu'il ya un
coronavirus qui est très proche de celui
donc
fameux qu'ovide 19 que nous avons donc
ça serait la source la sauce primitive
et donc des chercheurs peuvent étudier
il ya des gens qui vont chercher des
chauves souris dans des grottes au
vietnam en chine et qui étudie qui
peuvent faire un certain nombre de
travaux sur ces virus ensuite ce qu'on a
pensé si vous voulez c'est que la chauve
souris
elle s'alimente de bégonias ces deux
fruits particulier sur des arbres et
puisqu'elle urines
donc les fruits sont touchés par l'uriné
il peut y avoir des fourmis aussi qui
viennent et puis un animal qui vient
manger ces fourmis qui se contaminent
alors un moment on a dit ça peut être le
pangolin delphine wespiser est avec
merci ea delsinne d'amour je suis très
content que ce soit avec nous sylvie ou
geneviève de fontenay
il ya eu un loupé donc il ya des filles
clairement et je pense à rachel qui a
été vraiment j'adore at elle été blessée
de pas être dans le livre et je la
comprends mais moi ce que j'aimerais
juste dire et j'aimerais faire un gros
bisou à toutes les filles c'est que
malgré tout ça reste un concours de
beauté on dit qu'à la famille miss
france mais l'un dans l'autre les places
à la télé sont chers bien sûr on pensait
dit c'est une famille mais en même temps
on a tout des blessures l'une envers
l'autre parce qu'il ya quand même la
concurrence moi ce que j'aimerais c'est
que toutes les miss pour une fois on se
voit sans caméra sans instagram et tout
et qu'on se fasse vraiment une vraie
sortie
m pour vraiment créer des vraies mais
libéré jean-michel guerre parce que les
dacquois gt mais célibataire
mais ce message il est beau mais ça non
mais vous y prenez vous n'êtes plus
crédible des cas une belle fille qui
arrêtait tout elle est crédible à la
chose et moi ça c'est pas du tout ce
qu'a dit françois sens tu dois montrer
mon sac
nicolas un jour je prenne révélation à
c'est à dire c'est quoi son patron
nicolas pernikoff je vous le dis et us
et nicolas ajoute m et je le dis aux
téléspectateurs nicolas pernikoff été
directeur des divertissements de france
télévisions pendant très longtemps pour
moi je les dis je pensais était le
meilleur directeur des divertissements
de penser et nicolas vous avez une voix
particulière et il m'est arrivé de me
faire passer bon si c'est vrai auprès d'
animateur auprès des animatrices pour ça
que je suis grillé partout au président
de recherche auprès de l'accueil le
prince télévision en rappel sap et
l'accueil
alou c'est nicolas pernikoff directeur
des bons transversale
combien de fois j'ai appelé des gens
dont je m'honore mais c'était pour
rigoler bien entendu c'est d'ailleurs je
suis sur un groupe prime c'était une
prime pense à toi et nicolas voilà je
voulais vous dire parce que vous êtes un
ami je vous donnerai demain les noms à
qui j'ai fait ça au lin hall à licola ne
franchement au reste à nous on les
appellera pas quand même non vous at il
pas merci en tout cas c'est le retour du
rif ice l'application qui mélange nos
têtes avec celles d'autres stars n'a
isabella tu as construit et mini ratage
optique on a mis une amie isabelle dans
le corps emilie franchement c'est la
même si consécutif
ricco comme on dit regardez
[Musique]
papa
gratuit
et elle ses côtés la coquille regardez
où vous avez angel d'emballant jetons
quoi
[Musique]
pour
il est temps jul assez forts meilleurs
[Applaudissements]
au fait
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
leur action bondir le match j'oublie en
exclusivité pour touche pas à mon poste
regardez il rassure ancien ministre du
numérique et député la république en
marche
dans ce documentaire on vous dit que la
science vous ment dans ses documentaires
aux boutiques le gouvernement ne vit et
ne travaille que dans l'intérêt des plus
puissants et des plus riches
leur thèse c'est de vous dire en fait
c'est un groupe de personnes dans le
monde qui ne cherchent qu'une chose
c'est s'enrichir et exterminer les plus
pros c'est à cause de ce documentaire
les gens refusent de vacciner sa cause
documentaire les gens ne prennent plus
aucune responsabilité aucune distance et
qui continuent de propager les communes
partout alors ce documentaire il a rompu
le parc de liberté d'expression et il
met en danger des vies
je crois qu'il faut faire très attention
que tu me soumettent à hauteur de sa
responsabilité
nicolas il a d'autres mais c'est bien
sûr que s'il a totalement raison mais
est ce que vous imaginez aujourd'hui où
il ya tu disais que l'incivilité où il
ya des gens qui refusent de mettre le
masque
il ya des gens qui refusent plein de
choses vous rendez compte que ce que
peut véhiculer ce genre de documentaire
auprès des gens au xviiie siècle
tiens justement est la première de
france au xviiie siècle que voulait dire
la phrase
bonjour comment allez vous comment vous
d affaires comment va la famille comment
va ton caca ou comment vont les emplois
capillaire de jean michel maire mais
kelly place et je pensais car comment
va-t-on cacahouète c'est vrai c'est vrai
oui c'est est-ce que ça a été à la selle
est ce qu'il est ce que ce que vous êtes
bien d'aller à la selle c'est
effectivement ça il ya plein d'autres
expressions comme ça de la langue
française dont on soupçonne pas le sens
par exemple je sais pas si vous êtes
marié les uns et les autres mais passer
la bague au doigt ouais ok ça veut dire
quoi en fait c'est très c'est très
visuel impression voilà je vous salue et
à un acte sexuel tout ça
[Musique]
qu'est ce qui lui arrive j'ai montré
médecins aux interdits
[Rires]
et
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
thomas liberté
[Musique]